although our favorite web slinger is
technically dead right now after the
events of Avengers infinity war
Spiderman far from home is well underway
and although there have been many leaks
both photos and videos of the set we
still don't really know too much about
the story quick reminder about the
infinity war blu-ray giveaway if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero obviously
with spider-man far from home kicking
off phase 4 of the MCU Peter Parker
somehow gets resurrected in Avengers 4
and again not much is known about far
from home but it seems like he's gonna
have his work cut out for him right
after Avengers 4 there are several
villains that are said to be waiting for
him and spider-man far from home
including Mysterio vulture Hydra man and
chameleon and according to this rumor
molten man will be waiting for him as
well
molten man or mark roxton's origin is
connected to Spencer Smythe who is
another character that is rumored to be
in the movie the rumor comes from a toy
figurine that is being produced by one
of the toy companies for the film so I'm
hesitant to say that it has been
officially confirmed that multi-man will
be in the film but there has been a toy
of him produced this would not be the
first time that a toy has given away a
part of a movie if you recall with
Avengers infinity war we first found out
about Stormbreaker through a toy and
also in Avengers infinity war we found
out about spider-man's iron spider suit
through a toy I'm sorry you're giving
out tickets or something so there is
some validity of molten man appearing in
the film due to the fact that there is a
toy of him being produced if they have
all of the other villains that are
rumored to appear in spider-man far from
home and introduce molten man that would
be five villains currently said to be in
the movie five villains just one away
from six and the sinister six has been
rumored and hinted at that they could
show up in spider-man far from home or
the next spider-man movie what could
happen is that all of these villains
could be introduced in spider-man far
from home and in the next sequel they
could
all come together and form the sinister
six but again right now nothing is
officially confirmed so we'll have to
wait until we know a little bit more
information about spider-man far from
home I do not want another single
pop-culture reference out of you for the
rest of the trip you understand what do
you all think about multi man possibly
appearing as a villain and Spider Man
far from home also what do you think
about the possibility of the sinister
six showing up as well let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and
another reminder about the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
thank you so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]